in my last video I discussed how adding
a single card to an EDH deck that
simplifies or circumvents a task a
player finds fun can have a negative
impact on how playing that deck feels
that video generated a lot of Buzz and
discussion which was great to see and it
also helped crystallize a handful of
ideas that have been sloshing around my
brain for the past several months these
ideas are complicated and span a variety
of subjects but they can be pretty
straightforwardly introduced with a
simple thought experiment let's say you
have a tutor and there's a Bonkers card
something very powerful in your deck do
you tutor for the Bonkers card just so
things are a bit more tangible let's say
you're enlightened tutoring for a skull
clamp in a mid power tokens deck a
decently powerful tutor and a draw
engine that is probably Leaps and Bounds
better than the next most powerful draw
engine in the deck so do you Enlighten
tutor for the skull clamp I have devised
four answers to this question which
segment four different perspectives on
EDH philos opy and those go as follows
yes I tuted for the skull clamp because
I like skull clamp and I want to draw a
shitload of cards regardless of
situation no I might choose not to tutor
for the skull clamp because the number
of cards it draws might not fit the vibe
of this game no and in fact I cut the
enlightened tutor because I don't want
the option of tutoring for the skull
clamp no and in fact I cut the skull
clamp because the number of cards it
draws doesn't fit the vibe of my deck it
may be clear which of these quadrants I
personally fall into most frequently the
fourth one I found or sometimes the
first depending on Deck but I want to
acknowledge that the others exist I've
gotten a lot of comments from people who
likely Fall firmly into one of the first
three quadrants people saying something
to the effect of but wait Alex have you
considered this I think you forgot to
consider this so I now want to consider
the other three of these perspectives in
depth and where they come from what core
animating forces drive people to engage
with this format the way they do I've
split this video up into two parts
because I found that the first two
perspectives here and the last two
perspectives here really demand two
different lenses of analysis so if you
want to hear me discuss the final two
you can keep an eye out for that video
about a week from now but for now let's
get into the first two quadrants the
first one is the person who does tutor
for the good card because they want to
play the good card this is on its face
entirely understandable Magic the
Gathering is a card game where players
try to win games and when games is fun
more powerful cards win more games so
they end up being seen as especially fun
in some sense this may be directly
related to the fact that they win more
games but in a format like EDH it could
also be a more indirect Force they feel
good to play they generate reactions
from others they have a Mystique about
them born from years of being heralded
as powerful there's a reason why vintage
cube is one of the most popular Cube
formats on mtgo are these powerful cards
more inherent ly fun than any others no
but they're famous and alluring and
playing them pokes a little good card
dopamine button residing in the brains
of a lot of players the EDH player who
runs good cards and tuts to find those
good cards more often may be doing so
because they want to win more games but
they also may just be looking to poke
that button more and can you blame them
it's fun to play a skull clamp and draw
a ludicrous number of cards I think most
players go through a stage of this at
some point in time I certainly had the
experience of optimizing a mono black
pile with cabal coffers and necr poent
and such like 10 or so years ago and I
remember the excitement I felt for some
players that excitement persists long
term and I'm happy for those players
maybe they make their way to cedh or
maybe they just have a good time playing
sweaty high power piles against other
sweaty high power piles however for
myself and many others the excitement of
playing good cards for the sake of them
being good does start to fade with time
trotting out the same old powerful cards
in the same ways just might not remain
as enjoyable
and even if you do keep playing with
them you might need to change the way
you play with them to keep them fresh
one way this can be done is changing the
context in which you play a powerful
card an ancient tomb that curves into a
basa Citadel is very different from one
that curves into a bunch of tree folk
and a necropotence that draws into an
infinite combo is very different from
one that draws into a bunch of clerics
from the 2000s put another way powerful
cards can go from a fun thing in their
own right to a way to en en some other
fun things that are a bit less powerful
this isn't really a realm of deck
building I tend to find myself in but I
can absolutely see the appeal you get
the enjoyment of playing powerful magic
cards and the enjoyment of enabling
offbeat archetypes that might not be
good enough with weaker support cards
and going back to the premise of this
video tutors can help with this if you
want to guarantee having a piece of
powerful support to hold up your
otherwise questionable game plan tutors
can be a good way to do that to have a
consistent experience with your janky
deck this game doesn't have 10 necro
poces you can slip into your deck and
even if it did that might not even be
desirable tutors are a nice way to work
around that fact okay so that's one way
powerful cards can stay fresh playing
them in unusual contexts the other way
is getting to the point where you don't
even feel the need to play the good card
every time it's available and this
brings me to the second group of players
these are the players who have the tutor
and don't tutor for the skull clamp or
at least they don't always tutor for the
best possible option I found that these
are players who see tutors as a
wonderful and freeing tool you can find
whatever you want with them you can find
a skull clamp you can find a land you
can find a leeching licid the world is
your oyster and there is a certain logic
to this some games you might want a
power card maybe you're behind or maybe
you want a chance at catching up with
somebody running away with the game but
there also might be other games where
you'd prefer to take it a little EAS
easier play a little lower caliber tutor
for something a bit more mundane if it
better fits the vibe of the game you're
playing I believe this to be the least
popular of the four quadrants I laid out
earlier but for the people who fall into
it I'm genuinely happy for them they are
able to have fun doing something that I
struggle to have fun doing playing
suboptimally on purpose see I treat the
format of EDH as a two-stage game as I
discussed in more detail in a video
about combo decks last fall during the
first stage that deck building stage I'm
in creative mode crafting an experience
for the future me to play with thinking
about the sorts of decks I might be
facing and trying to fine-tune what I'm
building to create the most enjoyable
games during the second stage though
when I'm actually playing a game my
goals are somewhat different I treat it
as a game where my objective is winning
and where I'm pursuing that under a set
of constraints these constraints consist
of the tools given to me by my deck
building self as well as the limitations
of the type of table engagement I prefer
which is generally very open and
disclosing of information I think my
opponents should have I'm not doggedly
pursuing victory at all costs but I also
don't like playing suboptimally once I'm
in a game if I need to make a
sub-optimal choice or hold back in some
way it pierces the immersion of the game
and kind of takes me out of it I still
will do this under some circumstances
but I don't like doing it and I
certainly wouldn't set up my deck in a
way where I expect to need to do it on a
regular basis I know I'm not alone in
this either a lot of people dislike
playing suboptimally and another segment
of players dislike playing against
somebody they know is playing
suboptimally it almost feels like an
insult you can interpret somebody
choosing to make worse choices as them
saying Oh no I don't need to put full
effort into this game what you're doing
there isn't requiring that of me now
realistically the sort of player who is
okay with playing suboptimally probably
isn't thinking this way but for somebody
who is in a somewhat more competitive
mindset it's not hard to take this
interpretation this type of player may
also seem very different from most other
ways of playing the EDH format and
indeed it does take a different mindset
a different perspective on the nature of
winning a game maybe even different
ideas of what a game should look like
however going back to the two-phase
model of Magic the Gathering this
difference could be as simple as
reversing the ordering of optimization
in terms of deck building versus playing
I play in a more optimized style and
deck build in a less optimized style but
it's easy to imagine a type of player
who puts more optimization effort into
the deck building phase and is a bit
more laid-back and Casual when they're
actually playing I might feel a little
weird about somebody else making choices
that notably worsen their chances of
winning but I've also had people
complain about me making the same sorts
of choices in the deck building stage of
things the most dominant feature of
casual EDH is some degree of
suboptimality and I generally think of
that as being in the deck building part
of things but it's seems reasonable
enough that it could exist in the
playing stage instead as a final note
going back to the comparison between
these two player types a way that these
two players are a bit more similar is in
the character of their decks they're
generally both happy to play tutors and
they are both happy to play with
powerful cards as well maybe even when
those cards feel a bit overtuned
compared to the rest of the contents of
a deck fundamentally these things are
just game pieces and having them in a
deck isn't an obstacle to the fun for
these people what I'll be talking about
next week on the other hand is the
opposite it's players who are much more
critical of what they put in their deck
one way or another and as you'll see
when that video comes out those
particular perspectives have
philosophical Roots about as deep as
it's possible to be with that said
thanks for watching and thanks to
architect for supporting the channel
I've been doing a lot of Brewing lately
and architect makes it easy to keep my
thoughts organized with its nice visual
layout and helpful category system a
link to my is in the description if you
want to check out what I've been working
on lately I'd also like to thank my
patrons some of whom are on screen now I
just started taking submissions for this
month's Deck review so if you want a
chance at having your deck reviewed by
me you can sign up to my patreon at the
link in the description you can also
check out the podcast I'm on if you want
to experience more words exiting my
mouth without giving me more money a
link to that is also in the description
all right bye now